this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your mental
health your relationships your
boundaries or lack thereof i'm george
campbell ramsey personality joined today
by the inimitable dr john deloney
john good to see you wow look who's got
a dictionary yeah i've been hanging out
with ken coleman he's taught me a lot of
ten dollar words
he's gonna leave a comment on that we're
just gonna go i just threw a little
grenade over there just to see what you
do with it well folks it's open phones
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you've got a
question a burning question you want
some confirmation affirmation you want
us to talk you off the ledge of a
terrible financial decision you're about
to make we are here for you today so
give us a call phone lines are open
triple eight eight two five five two two
five mary kicks us off in kalamazoo mary
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can john and i help
well um
my husband and i are kind of in a sticky
situation with our
with my mother-in-law his mother
um
and
we don't really know if we should help
her how we should help her
right now she's going through a divorce
the reason of the divorce
being that she is a hoarder and
her soon-to-be ex-husband says that he's
been asking for help with those but she
hasn't been helping with those
she also has a mortgage on a house that
is
unlivable it's covered in mold
and
she wants to continue to live there
um
my husband's father
passed away
um
i left her i want to say about 200 000
um
but she's already spent it all
and while he was still alive he bailed
her out of half a million dollars in
debt oh
she's
yeah
she's not really being forthcoming
about any of her debt situation
and she has even gone as far to ask us
not to tell the rest of the family about
her divorce
which i think is going to be final in
about 30 days
so
now it's a situation of
and i i don't even know if this is the
correct
terminology or the correct thinking
um but is do we allow my mother-in-law
to
to live in a house that's covered in
molds that's hazardous to her health
and she's just gonna continue to be in
debt and be a hoarder or
do we intervene somehow
how do i navigate this so mary i'll jump
in here i
i hear it in you that you're just at
wit's end
and so a couple things i want to walk
you through about hoarding and then we
will get to
some steps y'all can take okay
um
hoarding is one of those words like
narcissus that gets thrown around a lot
all over the place um if it sounds like
she truly is hoarding right she she
truly is a hoarder i'm not i'm not
saying this lately oh no i trust i trust
you
when somebody is fully there um when
they get a rush uh on getting a good
deal or they're unable to maneuver in
their home it's unsanitary it's unsafe
and they are unable to move forward
i want you to
begin to shift your language
just you're gonna practice this i want
you to shift your language from she's
not coming she's not forthcoming she's
not
your your mother-in-law is very very ill
okay okay
um and so let's take the
moral stuff out let's take the character
stuff out um not long term right there's
still going to be some reckoning here
and we need to change some actions and
behavior but right now she's very very
sick she's not okay
um and
we could probably track this thing back
all the way to when she was a little
girl
um there's some trauma here that's been
there around for a long time it would be
my guess
but we're here now
so here's a hard truth
you can't make an adult do anything
yeah and there's few things on earth
more devastating than watching somebody
you love be in pain and not
take your help or your support or your
care because i know if she called you
and said i need this house cleaned up
this week you and your husband and
everybody else would take the week off
and go get that thing but it can't
absolutely of course you would and so
you are watching somebody that you love
drown
and you can yell all day long hey we'll
come out and get you we're here swimming
tread water next to you and they say
leave me alone leave me alone one of the
cornerstones of
true hoarding is a deep resounding shame
she knows what her house looks like
and she's found herself in a position
where she doesn't believe she can stop
she knows about the divorce and that
some of her actions have led to somebody
saying i can't be in a relationship with
you anymore
and it just that shame mounts and mounts
and mounts and rounds and mounts so
at some point
you can rally all of your husbands
brothers and sisters and he needs to
lead this his brothers and sisters need
to lead this you need to support him in
this this isn't your lead to take
but they either
show up with a mental health
professional and do an intervention
and say we're getting involved here
at knowing that mom can kick you all out
and or you can call some of the
resources in your community that says we
have an adult who is no longer able to
take care of themselves
and there is instances where the
local government will get involved that
gets messy mom will say mean things to
y'all
um
and that's just part of it and that's
okay because you're taking care of
somebody
but there's not going to be some magic
conversation that you the um
daughter-in-law can have and she'll go
oh i didn't think of that that's that's
not where we're at she's very very sick
okay
so the reason i tell you she's very sick
i want you to approach her with
compassion not with anger and
frustration even though you're gonna get
angry and frustrated
um and let's approach it from a
compassion lens and then let's say
we're gonna give you an opportunity to
be surrounded by people who love you and
say we're willing to get the big
dumpsters in here we're gonna help you
get some care she probably needs to go
see a doctor
not probably she for sure does
and if she won't do that then we're
going to call in some professionals here
in the community and say hopefully
they'll reach out they may not they may
not okay okay this is a hard hard messy
situation you are in um i let her know
we are not gonna loan you money
all the brothers and sisters we're not
gonna give you money we're not gonna
give you access to our credit cards um
and we're gonna go down those roads to
make sure everybody's on the same page
that we're gonna start taking care of
mom because she's not okay
okay
so
the other um
the other
issue that i'm having that i'm hurting
with
um
it's just such a black and white
difference between
her parenting versus
my parents
um yeah
i i would
it's hard for me to deal with and then i
know as as a wife and as a support to my
husband
um he's
told me that he promised his father on
his father's deathbed
that he would take care of mom that's
right and here's the deal taking care of
mom isn't giving mom everything she
wants taking care of mom
is
calling the professionals and the
interventionist who are going to help
pull her out of the water because she is
literally drowning don't compare your
parents you'll have two different sets
of parents who have different sets of
gifts and skills you love your parents
and you love her and how you love each
other is going to look differently for
both of you you can do this oh sorry
you're going through this mary
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper
start your cfo career
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality
joined today by best-selling author dr
john deloney
john we just took a
heartbreaking call
a woman called in her mother-in-law is a
hoarder
the father had passed away and she's
just spiraling out of control and it
reminded me of of the importance of
getting well while you can and we
believe there's hope for everyone that
it's never too late and the way you
unpack a clear path in this book for
people who aren't scientists like me
is absolutely incredible so own your
past change your future it's on
pre-order now you get a free month
from better help of weekly one-on-one
therapy which is incredible on its own
lots of bonuses there
but tell us what someone can use this
book for to get well so i think people
think of mental health i think of that
woman in that call right my
mother-in-law is a has a psychiatric
disorder that she is struggling for
burning through money she's unable to
help herself so we think about mental
health we think of that you think of
extreme cases major cases
this book is not for that situation it
can it can support that situation but
this book is for
that woman who just called
how do i keep myself and my family okay
when we're trying to love somebody who's
struggling
how do i
live in a world where this country just
invaded that country and we're still
coming out of pandemic and i haven't
paid my student loans off yet and
or what's happening with our government
i got how do i be okay in that mess and
that
is all of us that's me right that's
everybody man that's dave that's you
that's all everyone's got levels of
trauma no matter if they think they do
or not there's stuff that happened in
their life and when we don't deal with
it it comes out in weird ways and then
we wake up one day going why is my life
just kind of suck yeah and so whenever
it's just an expansion of man we hear
mental health and relationships we hear
that stuff all the time and we think
that's for those people it's for all of
us for all of us and so uh most most
mental health books talk at you all of
them they talk at you
um it was really important to me that
man this is this is my journey too like
i'm this is just a couple of folks
sitting on the back of a tailgate going
which is a very texas reference by the
way
i've never done that john in your case
sitting in a brand new nissan leaf thank
you plugged in thank you um says the guy
who drives the prius okay i used to
until i wrapped it until i slid it down
the uh the concrete barrier here on 65
but that's for another day that's
another day um but it's for all of us
just having a conversation saying i'm
i'm just walking alongside you i love it
well folks you're never too old you're
never too young to improve your health
and make those relationships stronger to
deal with those past traumas so that you
can be well
and you get a free month of one-on-one
weekly therapy from our friends at
betterhelp which will give you some
tools that you need to change your
future and you're going to match with a
therapist based on your specific needs
so i love this combo dr john deloni's
new book own your past change your
future plus a month of therapy from
better help this book's going to make
you laugh it'll make you cry it's going
to challenge you it's going to help
unpack some of those bricks that you've
been carrying around for way too long
and when you take these steps that dr
john outlines and take advantage of that
free therapy you will be transformed and
that's what we're all about here at
ramsey we're in the transformation
business so go get yours it's 20 bucks
for all this stuff that's amazing ramsay
solutions.com is the place to do that
and they've got some cool bonuses uh
with the conversation cards the
questions for humans right now so go
check all that out at
ramseysolutions.com all right
let's move on to olivia she's on the
line in miami florida olivia welcome to
the ramsay show
hi george hi john how are you doing
great how can we help
so i recently moved to florida and
my rent actually increased i've been
following financial peace university
since 2020 but i didn't really
kind of follow all the rules i kind of
messed up and got myself a little bit
deeper into debt so i kind of started
doing it all over again and uh but my
rent increased and i'm i'm thinking um
should i put the baby steps on hold and
focus on it finding a cheaper apartment
or should i just stay where i am for now
well i don't think this is an emergency
situation where we put the steps on hold
what we do have to do is look at our
budget and find margin and there's only
two ways to create that margin number
one is increase our income and number
two is decrease our expenses and the
combination of those things hopefully
will get you to a point where you're
going to be able to afford that rent and
keep on with the baby steps so when you
say you did something dumb what'd you do
i got a car i financed the car oh you're
calling about i get a cheaper apartment
and then you made a what's this car what
is it
yeah
uh i so i got a a car loan in 20 like
2020 um so that ended up kind of being
the mistake there so it's kind of the
expense of paying for the car and
student loans and credit cards and
everything it's just kind of kicking my
butt plus plus the inflation well the
good news about cars is that it's
usually a reversible decision so what's
the car worth
the car right now uh the last time i
tried i checked it was like 10 000
but my my car payments are 15. like the
total i should say is 15 000. so the
loan is for 15 000
yes and the car is only worth 10.
yes i would go check on that that feels
really low since you bought that in 2020
cars have appreciated in the most
bizarre way have you checked on it
recently
yeah i have because i was trying to
trade it in for something um cheaper and
uh they would it turned out that i would
have negative equity so all right okay
so what's your take-home pay right now
every month
it's i take home about 20 uh sorry i
take home 2 000 a month
and what's your rent
my rent is 12.50 ouch you can't even
breathe olivia what are you doing
i know is this a one bedroom apartment
yeah
okay and you're living alone obviously
yes okay it may be time to
move out and move in with someone else
as a roommate
have you thought about that option
i actually just came out of a roommate
situation so i kind of didn't want to go
back into that okay olivia let me say
this because george is really kind you
are broke
you're drowning
you can't breathe okay how do we get
this income up is another part of the
equation
you you definitely have to move out you
can't afford this even if you got a
raise today this is insane to be paying
this much with your take-home pay
yeah so what are you doing for work
i work in uh pharmacy as a pharmacy tech
okay
and you're making 24 a year after taxes
uh 30 a year after taxes okay
i think we need to find a way to get
this income up
yeah maybe temporary so here's what
happened you found yourself and you're
broke
you followed america to florida and
shockingly when all of america wants to
live in a place then the rents go way up
and they can just move them up
willy-nilly because there's a line of
people from california new york who will
take that spot behind you
you're gonna have to be radical for a
season in a season i mean probably two
years
and i mean radical like you're gonna
work a full day as a farm tech and then
you're gonna go over work another shift
at a local hospital or you're gonna go
deliver uh pizzas you're gonna you drive
for lift you're gonna do whatever for
two years
and you're gonna
pay this sucker off and pay your stupid
student loans off and you're gonna have
a knuckleheaded roommate that's so
annoying
they're safe but god almighty they're
annoying
in every day you're going to say never
again never again never again
you hear what i'm saying
yeah
how old are you
i'm 26.
just close your eyes for a second real
tight and think about being 28 and not
own anybody anything as you move into
your new apartment and you'll have
gotten a new job because you're gonna
have so much new muscle
you'll be a gangster
like you know what i mean that like so
yeah i know i'm sounding like man that
guy needs to take a couple of xanax and
chill out i know i sound like that but i
don't know you realize how scary things
are for you
yeah i actually do realize
but like my budget has been really tight
like i've been really good with my
budget so i've been just been able to
kind of stay afloat but it's it's really
hard yeah have you gone through
financial peace university
i have i just started um the baby steps
i'm at baby step one good awesome well
how much debt do you have total
in total it's about 48 000.
okay
you can do this but like john's saying
you're gonna have to do some radical
things sacrifice get the roommate take
the second job take the third job get
your income up slash the budget even
further for a season
six and a half days a week and if you
can sacrifice for two years the next 20
after that are going to be amazing 30 40
after that 50. we'll keep going to live
forever she's gonna go forever that's
financial freedom well we're pulling for
you thanks for the call this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
deloney and in the lobby of ramsay
solutions on the debt-free stage greg
and becky join us how are you guys we're
good
where are you from
north mankato minnesota minnesota all
the way to do a debt-free scream that's
right how much have you guys paid off
uh 158 000.
how long did that take uh four years and
nine months nice awesome and what was
the range of income during that time
85 to
115. all right what do you guys do for a
living i'm a controls tech and becky is
a fitness instructor and manager at a
gym awesome what is a controls tech that
hurt my brain i do uh programming um
with uh
programmable logic controllers
i do not understand plc's words but it
sounds like you're a really smart and
that you could blow us all up so i love
you and i'm glad that you're here it's
all knows enough to be dangerous okay so
there's 158 000 what kind of debt was
this it was um mostly a lot of it was
student loans and then it's our house
too
okay mike dropped
we're looking at weird people got a
minnesota house yeah that's very amazing
so casual yeah just some loans in a
house no big deal dude he's a control
tech he doesn't have
wow this is incredible okay so let's
talk about this four years and nine
months ago when you guys had the loans
you also had the mortgage and you just
went we're just doing this thing what
happened well we we were invited we were
meeting with some friends and they were
all going to go on this sandals trip and
they invited us to go but we were like
well we weren't married yet we wanted to
be married we were like well we have all
this debt too
and we don't want to go on this trip and
like
have all these other expenses and come
back and be stressed out still so for us
it was
let's take the time now and pay off this
debt and then we can go on these trips
and actually go and enjoy them and have
fun wait you guys just like made an
adult decision to just have patience we
really did haven't you seen the sandals
brochures though it looks so nice they
still have one sure is john i don't know
yeah on the covered wagon i take home so
were you guys always kind of disciplined
but just kind of ish
um i think i always wait i try i bet was
working really hard to get duffery um
before i'd met craig and he was
definitely more financially savvy than i
was and then once we
we met and we were talking about getting
married he was like have you ever heard
of like dave ramsey or these other like
finance whatever and i was like no i
don't know anything about it i'm just
trying to pay my car off like
so and he was really good at guiding me
and getting me on track with that so how
did you get connected greg with our
crazy crew um i think just internet
research just
reading and learning about you know what
is money what should you do what you do
not do and
came upon dave ramsey wow anyway this
guy's got a good head on his shoulders
let's go with his plan instead of mine
yeah exactly wow well four years and
nine months that's a long journey to a
lot of people
to become debt-free i mean obviously
house and everything that's absolutely
incredible how did you guys stay
motivated on this path
well some big motivations where we have
really good friends who have paid off
their mortgages too so that was like
huge my mom paid off hers too wow it
just was like when they would do that
was more inspiring for us to be like
okay our friends can do this like we can
do this too we can crack down and keep
going and do it again so you saw it done
from people that are just like you and
you're like wait if they can do it we
can do this exactly different exactly so
over the last four and a half years
recount your
your most legendary
marital fight over this budget
um well budgeting for me is always just
a little stressful and very emotional
and i pretty much cry every time
wow
because greg has like i would like to do
it this way and i think we should really
watch this and i'm like oh so i'm the
more emotional one for the way you walk
it's a little bit this and this and i
cry every time
that's fantastic greg what about you man
um i i just remember well the first time
she cried um we were talking about uh we
were actually getting rid of uh a little
credit card and we fell for the delta
thing where hey we're going to get a
bunch of points and get those sky miles
yep and
yeah so we we were trying to then redeem
and it was such a hassle and it turned
out we couldn't redeem and get like the
trip we wanted to get and
oh it turns out there's all these hoops
to jump through and it just didn't work
yeah if you want to go to nebraska in
2027 on a tuesday
and we got the points for you that's
right exactly and you're on a delta
flight so that's right
wow wow and here you guys are house paid
for and everything yes talk to that
couple who may be sitting there with a
hundred and fifty eight thousand dollars
and they go well we're just never going
to pay this off oh it i mean it
definitely we talked about it on our
drive down yesterday how
like getting to the end point was just
but just writing out the goals and
having like visuals and and listening to
the show and hearing other people pay
off their houses too was huge and
inspiring and kept us motivated yeah i
mean it's definitely it's hard but when
you really sit and think about like the
rewards at the end
and to start out like we're gonna have a
baby soon and so we know like we don't
have to worry about that stuff
congratulations so nice yeah yes bring
him bring it into the world debt-free
yeah that's the way to do it
exactly yeah and when you surround
yourself with a bunch of uh you know
negative nancies who go well you'll
always have a car payment no one pays
off it's actually stupid to pay off your
house actually i talked about that too
how they were my cheerleaders as well
like i
loved when people said that to me
because i was like
i'm gonna show you that i'm gonna get
this done i don't want to have a car
payment i don't want to have a mortgage
for the rest of my life i want to live
our lives and travel and like
you know do what we want to do so it was
just motivating when people would tell
us oh no you'll have that forever you
love both you love the support and you
love the negativity both fueled you in
in their own ways yes you've done this
stuff oh greg what do you tell that that
husband who's
sitting with his wife over across the
table and they're doing their first
budget and she just starts crying um i
think just be patient and you know you
may have the uh you you might have
figured out you know uh mathematically
how
this could be done the best but listen
to her because she may have a really
good solution that
you know you just didn't think of dude
you should start a marriage podcast
hold on the key to a good marriage is
patience and listen yes and and i know
you've got it all figured out but maybe
she's got an idea too dude you're a
genius guys
wow so you've done this stuff what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
well we definitely like we know everyone
says budget and it is it's huge to work
on that budget and do the zero based and
figure out where your money is going is
just yeah it's the the best part
so yeah for us that was the biggest
thing and like saying no
and just keep keep your keep listening
to the ramsay show and keep listening to
other people as they pay off and like
like fight through these things too have
you had the moment yet when
you've got your checks deposited and
you don't have any payments it's our
money yeah it's really crazy it still
doesn't feel that real but you know
we're a few months into the new year and
we're like oh we can do what we want
it's just all deposits and it's all yeah
look at greg look at you smiling man
that's a good feeling that's the biggest
tech smile i've ever seen that's
fantastic he's beaming yes how does it
feel to be completely 100 debt free and
not owe anyone anything
it's awesome very good yes it's
incredible
we love it
so it's hard not to love john you know
there's a lot to love there when you
don't have any payments to make at the
end of the month and you get to keep it
you get to now you can go to sandals
like every month if you want oh sure yes
that's right and your friends hey we
can't sorry we're broke
and gender reveal little girl little boy
it's a little boy little boy yes i'm
just saying john is a better name than
george congratulations congratulations
both are kind of lame but you know you
can do better is all i'm saying
well guys we're so proud of you you guys
are heroes and you're gonna inspire a
lot of couples out there who didn't
think it was possible who may be in the
journey with you trying to pay off this
house and they heard greg and becky and
they went this is keeping us going yeah
so thank you for being here thanks for
making the trip yeah we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires that's dave's
number one national bestselling book
that's the next chapter for you guys as
you build wealth and give outrageously
for the rest of your entire lives and we
also have a copy of total money makeover
and i want you to give it to that person
who was super negative and go hey just
slip it over and say i know this is
going to be a coaster for a little while
but you'll get there yeah and maybe next
year you can come to sandals with us
boom boom i like that
well let's get to the big moment here
it's greg and becky minneapolis
minnesota area 158 thousand dollars paid
off house and everything in four years
and nine months making 85 up to 115
count it down guys let's hear a debt
free scream
[Music]
just like that another couple gets set
free
we love to hear it this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsay personality and
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast joined today by dr
john delaney host of the dr john dalone
show
okay john it's america's favorite time
i uh we found a new tick tock video for
you i know how much you love the tick
tock with all of my heart just as much
as you love the internets
i love them all and with any social
media platform there's a lot of great
things that can happen on there and
there's a lot of not great things and
sometimes just sometimes john we like to
highlight the not so great things bring
it on let's do it a lot of financial
advice out there especially when it
comes to crypto a lot of fomo a lot of
people trying to get in on the next big
coin and so i thought we would watch a
video together and just see how you
react to it john you ready for this i am
people getting nutritional advice
and mental health advice
and now money advice from teenagers on
the tick tocks
that's congratulations america we've
done it roll the clip everyone gets a
platform okay everybody gets that's
right let's see what we got here
remember john your mic is hot so choose
your words
here's what would have happened had you
invested your 1200 stimulus check that
was first issued on april 12 2020 into
these top 10 most popular
cryptocurrencies twelve hundred dollar
investment into bitcoin today would now
be worth seven thousand five hundred and
thirty eight dollars twelve hundred
dollar investment into ethereum would be
worth twenty two thousand nine hundred
and twenty nine dollars into eta would
now be worth seventy six thousand three
hundred and sixty three dollars into bnb
would now be worth twenty eight thousand
seven hundred and twenty dollars two
hundred dollar investment into xrp would
now be worth five thousand eight hundred
and seventy three dollars into solana
would be worth a whopping two 210
389
into chain link would be worth eight
thousand five hundred and forty four
dollars i think he's doing that would be
worth a hundred and twenty six thousand
dollars into litecoin would be four
thousand five hundred and ninety five
and a 1200 investment into tara luna
would now be worth 180 thousand dollars
well george might have been back
they're back john
wow you know what else is cool if i had
not gone to taco bell yesterday i
wouldn't have indigestion is that how
that works
you know what he didn't play he didn't
play the other 10th
gosh dude
so let's just recap what just happened
john first of all i think he made up
about 17 words in there
how do people just keep up man
uh and here's the other thing
hindsight is 20 20.
john you're an idiot if you invested in
apple in 1984 just a hundred dollars
you'd be a millionaire but you know if
you'd gotten off your horse in 1806 and
and and put some money in ford shares
you'd be a gajillionaire so john i was
just in vegas and i i put 16 black and i
went all in on it i won big you should
also put 16 on black next time you go
yeah because that's the winning number
this is such a terrible use of
statistics everybody
ah jeez i don't know if we can call it
statistics i think professors all over
are angry right well it's just this it's
this
oh man you got john all breathy america
look what you did because i hate the
manipulation of data to a make people
feel
dumb
for choices they
could have made and i'm gonna go with
should've because we actually have a
real doubt of what these things are
worth today oh yeah yeah producer james
pulled that i can't stand it when people
say
well if you had of so you should
because there is zero none zilch
correlation
right and it left out
10 000 other
crypto like like whatever cartoons drawn
with some kid's laptop it left all that
out who people lost their their minds
right so you take a narrow snapshot of
those things and it makes you feel
stupid and left out and then that's
going to encourage people to go make
some reckless choices with their money
and it's that kind of nonsense hurts
people it's not helpful no it's not
helpful not at all it just gets you it
makes you feel
more so
i missed out i missed out again on the
next big thing
and as we know timing the market is the
most dangerous thing you can do and we
say it's not about time in the market
it's not about timing the market it's
about time in the market it's about
consistency over time when it's up when
it's down you're consistent you're
investing in things that have a stable
long proven track record that's why we
recommend mutual funds over the next
meme coin that just came out so producer
james pulled up some using the same
logic pulled up some interesting stats
here if you had invested twelve hundred
dollars into ethereum in november 2021
as of january you would have 840.
there goes 400 bucks right there
if you invested 1200 into bitcoin in
early november 2021 as of mid-january
you would have 660 dollars
congratulations just lost half your
money
if you invested 1200 into dogecoin in
may of 2021 as of january you would have
three hundred and sixty dollars instead
of twelve hundred and i know this for a
fact john here's why
when we were doing the episode on
cryptocurrency on the fine print podcast
which you can go listen to wherever you
little school boys everywhere were angry
with you they yeah they're very upset
with me here's what i did i i had to
know the experience
of what it's like to actually invest in
something so i didn't spend more than i
was willing to lose
i put 40 into dogecoin it was 40 cents
at the time so i got 100 doge dogecoin
and i went all right let me just see the
experience
number one it's traded 24 7. so i can be
up at 3 a.m watching it zing up and down
like a roller coaster going oh there
goes my money oop i made a dollar oh i
lost five dollars this is very stressful
so then we wonder why there's rampant
anxiety and stuff like following your
wife around be like you like me do you
like me now do you like me now how about
now so that was one piece of it but that
forty dollars can i tell you what it is
today john
according to that dude on the tick tocks
it's worth 111 million dollars it's
worth 14
that 40 dollars turned into 14. just
ride the wave and this was before elon
musk was saying hey doge to the moon and
he went on snl and everyone thought this
is our chance to get rich quick and doge
crashed after he went on snl and
mentioned dogecoin
so
don't let billionaires dictate how your
investments do hold on with one thing
they said on snl i'll i'll even give
billionaires like i think that's a good
like how'd you how did you if i see
somebody who's in great shape i might
ask them hey what are some things you do
in your life that puts you in a great
shape
and i got to filter that through my life
and my body and my blood types and my
experience and blah blah
who i'm not going to ask is some
nameless hand on the tick tocks
i don't know who that is
i don't you know what i mean yeah i
don't know what that guy is i'm not
gonna say you're right i screwed up
because i don't even know if that data
is true and if that's accurate it's just
certainly not accurate right now you
know what i mean yeah gosh that's the
experience and generally if you're
telling someone to invest in a certain
coin it's because you invested in that
coin and if they invest then you make
more money it's like a multi-level
marketing scheme especially i think i'm
glad you brought that up and this is me
being totally serious
if somebody who's a billionaire comes
out on a platform and i'm not saying
they're evil guys but
they come out and say
here's where i'm putting my money
they know
that a bunch of people will rush out and
put their money there which props up the
price
and they can get out
and they've got a million followers or
10 million followers or 100 million
followers and so if you are trying to
it's like this how often have we
not you i'll say thank you john how
often have i watched a pro athlete
documentary and i look at their workouts
and i'm like that's what i'm doing
tomorrow and i'll look start watching
their like the weights they're lifting
and squatting and i'll think all right i
need to up my game no
they play for a professional team this
is their job mine is to run my mouth on
the radio right
i shouldn't be lifting like a pro
athlete yeah following the dollar
amounts and the scale that some of these
folks are investing in if that thing
goes down you know what they still have
a billion dollars you know what you have
14. that was your whole life savings
while you're strapped with payments so
they can drag you into this thing prop
their thing up and get out and they've
got a they're it's a much different game
they're playing even though the
the the the process looks the same yeah
so man don't make choices with your life
and don't invest in things that you
don't understand and i'll tell you john
i've done a lot of research on crypto
and nfts and the more i research it the
dumber i think i'm getting the i'm like
maybe i'm just not a smart person
because this is so complicated which
makes me think maybe it's not designed
to actually make me rich
it's designed to help other people get
rich and then get out
so there's your uh your little pro tip
for the day on cryptocurrency if you
want to learn more about this stuff we
did a whole episode on the fine print
all about the hidden truths that are
keeping people broke it's called could
bitcoin be your ticket to wealth and if
you want to join us we are going to be
going to orlando with a building wealth
event where we show you the right way to
build wealth so you can check all of
that out at ramseysolutions.com thank
you for making me dumber today george
you're welcome it wasn't hard i don't
know what that says about you it's a low
bar
that puts this hour of the ramsay show
in the books my thanks to my fantastic
co-host dr john baloney all the folks in
the booth keeping the lights on keeping
the audio going and of course you
america appreciate you listening we'll
be back with you before you know it
[Music]
hey it's john dolone co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your mental
health your relationships everything
that matters to you we are here to talk
about it i'm george campbell joined
today by the infamous the legendary dr
john deloney and we're taking your calls
so give us one triple eight eight two
five five two two five for you younger
folks out there there's an app on your
phone that says phone and you tap that
and then type in 888-825-5225
you will get connected to kelly she's
very nice she's not going to hurt you
and you will get patched through to me
and john we'll have a good time
did you just did you just tell the the
youngsters how to it's a tutorial how to
work a telephone they need it did you
know that it makes calls
yeah okay but i was born in the 18th
century that's true all right
significant upgrade haley is waiting for
us john she's in milwaukee wisconsin
and let's go to her right now hayley
welcome to the ramsay show
hi
um
my seven-year-old son with adhd has been
in traditional school for the past four
years
but now this upcoming year we'll be
homeschooling him while sending my my
neurotypical four-year-old son to
traditional schools
so i just want to know how i can nurture
their relationship so that they aren't
comparing
themselves to each other in a damaging
way
how can i can like support their
emotions through this life change
um
i think you put everything on the table
and what i mean by that is
you have to everybody's got to parent
their kids differently and the last 20
years or so we've got this weird thing
about everything's got to be perfectly
equal which has turned into everything's
gonna be exactly the same
and every one of your kids has different
needs um i've got one kid who loves the
outdoors and i've got one kid who would
like to go outside never ever again ever
and so one kid um i can hold accountable
and say well you got to stay inside the
rest of the day and it's like no and the
other kid i say you got to spend the
rest of the afternoon outside and so
it's just a matter of
being comfortable parenting them both
differently what are you worried about
um
truthfully
my
my child with adhd actually loves loves
loves loves school
and why are you taking it why are you
taking them out um
his needs um it truthfully is his needs
um
tell me more about that what's that mean
um so we tried medication with him and
sometimes it actually makes his um
interruptions worse sometimes it makes
it better we're working on the dose
still so we're still kind of in this
newly diagnosed transitional phase but
is he getting
take the diagnostics off take the
medication off take everything off um
tell me what your little boy is going
through at school
okay the teachers um say that he is too
disruptive um just calling out a lot to
the point where and too distracted to
the point that they just don't think
he's getting anything academically out
of it yes he's getting socialization and
that's why he loves school so we're
gonna try to
i think we're going to try to find some
place that he loves just as much i guess
we're just concerned that he's not going
to equate whatever socialization we give
him it's like the same as school just
because that's all he's known for the
last four years
is this a public is this a public school
um this one's a private but when we talk
to public they said that they
yeah he was too high functioning for any
type of services whatsoever so that's
why we're like we need to and i also
read the book he recommended a scattered
mind and we're like you know what let's
just give him all the attention at home
that we possibly can and see how much
that helped so that's why we want to go
that route with him
but my younger kid he doesn't exactly
like school but we know that that it's
because of the socialization and we know
that that's what he needs so it's just
kind of
trying to we think that this is what
they do need but they could be wrong so
so
let me give you a little bit of peace
about a few things okay
give it a shot
and if two months in you realize
man
we need to get this thing figured out he
needs to be at school with his peers
with some structure we need to have a
daily routine that is that is relatively
firm so that um
he can begin to practice boundaries i'm
talking about your your son who's
struggling with um
impulse control
yeah
if
that might be where you are and so you
won't have failed anything you will have
been a a mother who loves her kid and is
trying
okay and then we'll say well we'll get
you back in and then you'll get back in
they're young it's it's fine and vice
versa
hold it loosely okay
the second thing is is a public school
is obligated
to take care of the needs of its
students
and
private schools some are great
some are notoriously terrible because
they can't afford the resources to take
care of students with non-traditional
learning exceptionalities okay
so
if you have a
diagnostic and you've sat down with a
the got all the psychological testing
and you sit down with the public school
they have to meet those needs
it's just a lot so then what steps what
so then what steps do i take then if
they are saying that according to their
assessment it's doesn't you know like he
doesn't need as many services as what we
um the other
assessments are saying you know what i
mean like the particular school we're
going to isn't matching the needs that
we think
the psychologist even thinks that he
needs
um
generally a school can't override that
there's gonna have to be some pretty
firm conversations about that and
there's okay there's entire programs
that go to war against schools who say
nah you're a doctor a psychologist or
this professional's wrong we're going to
just do it like this
and
in defense of the schools of which i've
worked in
sometimes the change of environment the
change of structure the change of a
number of things my son went from a
private school to a public school that
had
infinitely less boundaries to infinitely
more
and has absolutely soared just a
different environment
okay so sometimes the environmental
change all of this
is to say
your kids will absorb your tension
your kids will absorb your indecision
your kids will absorb your fear
and so say we're doing the best we can
with what the information we got we
think this is best for you we're the
parents and we're gonna stay plugged in
with you we're gonna stay plugged in
with the teacher and then we're gonna
make the best decisions in real time as
we move along
okay you know what i mean and if you
choose home school great go all in do a
great job at him do a great job your son
may i mean you may get it may become
a peaceful i mean you have no idea
what's gonna happen or you may know a
month in
i think that um we're gonna bury each
other and in the backyard and this is
not going to work for our family great
then we'll go back to we'll go to public
school and then we'll talk about the
arts and the 504 stuff and we'll get
through all that stuff with the doctors
okay but i want you to be at peace
the thing i i want you to not do is
don't hold hide hide this stuff from
your kids don't keep secrets
okay here i'm saying just be honest with
them tell them what we're doing in
age-appropriate language and then we're
gonna go from there
they are lucky to have you
they're lucky that you're their mom
because you care about them and you're
trying whatever's going to work for them
i want you to exhale
and no i'm doing a good job i love these
kids i'm working hard
and then we're going to hold it loosely
we're gonna make changes where we need
to
good for you a lot of wisdom there john
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm ramsey personality george campbell
joined today by dr john delony this is
the ramsay show open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
all right john occasionally we get a
question from social media and
occasionally we take that question and
today we have one from olivia in texas
and she writes in on youtube
i just finished funding my six month
emergency fund and i'm ready to start
investing
what are the best retirement plans to
invest in i love this olivia way to go
first of all for getting debt free
building that emergency fund of six
months and now you're at baby step four
you're ready to begin investing that 15
of your household income into retirement
i have a feeling i know what you're
going to say you're not going to say
open a deutsche
coin account no crypto we're not doing
that today i meant get on the internets
and find a bunch of
artwork digital artwork no nfts either
john
okay let's stick to the basics here here
are my two favorite retirement plans to
invest in number one is the 401k
that is going to be through your
employer and it's just a type of account
it's not an actual investment in and of
itself you want to actually put
investments inside of that 401k like
good growth stock mutual funds that we
talk about all the time the other type
of retirement plan that i recommend is
an ira that stands for individual
retirement arrangement did you know that
john i was going to say individual
retirement account they're
interchangeable but the official
terminology is arrangement and this is
basically another retirement account
that's outside of your employer so
anyone with earned income can go open an
ira and start investing so i can't go
open if i like had a great lawn business
i couldn't just go open a 401 k on my
own i need to start open an ira
yes okay now you there are employment
options if you're self-employed there's
other options right we'll get into it
another time okay but it sounds like
she's she's got a normal employer here
so let's talk about this traditional so
a traditional 401k traditional ira that
doesn't mean it's old-timey it just
means that the money that you put in
there
is pre-tax
and that means that it's tax deferred
growth meaning you will pay taxes on
that when you pull the money out in
retirement after 59 and a half so let's
say i put a hundred thousand dollars in
it grows to be a million dollars when i
start pulling it out i'm gonna pay tax
on the nine hundred thousand dollars
that it's grown right you'll pay taxes
on all of what i would draw yes and
here's the beautiful part about
traditional is that there are tax
advantages so you can deduct that amount
from your taxable income when it comes
time to uh when it comes to tax time
okay so that's the nice part about
traditional but let me tell you about
another friend named roth so on the
other side is roth and what i love about
roth is that it grows tax-free meaning
if i have a million dollars in my roth
401k i have a million dollars i can go
spend and uncle sam can't touch his
hands on it but i put it in there
after taxes exactly so you're already
paying taxes on that money before it
ever goes into the account so either way
you're paying taxes let's make that
clear this isn't like a tax hack we're
getting around the irs we're going to
pay taxes on this money it's just a
question of am i going to do it now or
am i going to do it later in retirement
so i'm a big fan especially for younger
people out there to open up a roth 401k
or roth ira if you have that option here
at ramsey we have a roth 401k
it's a fantastic option and i do my
entire 15
in our roth 401k and the beautiful part
is here ramsey and many employers they
have a match and so the match is free
money it's a hundred percent uh return
on that investment so ramsay puts four
percent in when i put four percent in
that is already right there so we say
that match beats roth be traditional
meaning we want to take the match first
then we want to move into a roth option
so if you don't have a roth option at
work let's go to the roth ira let's
fully fund that then let's move back to
the 401k the traditional side and finish
out that 15
very cool now if you have a roth 401k
and you've got good investment options
in there that's great but the ira will
give you way more options i mean the
sky's the limit with an ira the 401k is
limited in the investment so you want to
make sure you've got good gross stock
mutual funds in there that have a good
proven track record and many people do
combinations depending on their
situation but reminder a roth 401k a
401k an ira these are not actual
investments they're just a bucket it's a
jar that you can then put investments in
and they are tax advantaged which i love
and remember we want to diversify here
john we don't want to put all of our
eggs in one basket
i remember this yeah yeah one time
it was one time i had a basket of eggs
and i said hey john hold this one basket
for me and then i slapped it out of his
hand and went it was it was wild i know
i've talked to my therapist about it
oh you have a therapist no actually i
talked to it's just james yeah that's
right
well uh i mean that sums it up for for
investment accounts it's when it comes
down to it it's so simple people try to
rip through once dude no and that's the
thing
people over complicate investments and
that's when things get out of hand
that's when they make bad financial
decisions because they think my buddy
told me about this investment over here
i should be doing man the millionaires
that we talk to the stats are incredible
79 percent became millionaires they say
due to their employer-sponsored
retirement plan
a 401k that's it if you want to become a
millionaire you don't need to get rich
quick you don't need to hit it big at
the slots you just need to do something
simple and boring consistently over a
long period of time that is how the
majority of millionaires got there and
by the way that same advice works for
you want to become a better husband a
better wife
better girlfriend better boyfriend
do little things consistently over time
you want to get in shape
be consistent with a workout do it
on a regular schedule there's no hack
for me to get a six-pack by tomorrow
john there's a few and you'll pay for
them later right yes um same with like
changing your nutrition i mean it's
everything is be consistent do it over
and over over a period of time and the
results take care of themselves that's
right wow thank you so much for the
question olivia call us back when you're
a millionaire
all right let's go to the phones adam
joins us in new york city adam welcome
to the ramsay show
are you with us adam
we lost adam
it was so close we were so close to
helping adam and then we lost him
well we can we can move on right kelly
do you feel good about this okay all
right oh
he's back what's up adam who's on mute
all right hey
what's up dude can we help man that was
a close one almost lost you guys no we
almost lost you you would have been our
first what's up man
um so i'm 26 thousand dollars in debt um
23 of that is in a car and three isn't a
credit card
and um the car is way too much the
payments are just
a big hassle every week every month um
i was just trying to see if i can
relinquish the car or maybe find someone
to transfer the payments to so i don't
have to pay for any more is it a lease
or is it a traditional loan it's a loan
okay what's the car worth
uh it's worth 17
500 i believe 17 500.
okay well one option is you keep the car
and you keep making payments but it
sounds like that is not an option you
can afford
yeah it's just it's killing me so
in that case you're going to be in the
hole by about six thousand dollars right
yeah
how much money do you have saved right
now um
like a thousand all together okay so you
have that baby step one thousand dollars
when you say this thing's worth
seventeen thousand bucks is that did you
go
call somebody and have them appraise it
or is that you looking on kelly blue
book
yeah i went on a couple websites and you
all said about the game okay that's
private sale six thousand is is six
thousand underwater
yeah okay all right well that's going to
be your best bet i mean you could get a
personal loan from your credit union
it's the only time we would ever tell
you to go get a loan is when you're
under water on a car but i still don't
love that option for you what's your
household income
uh it's about 30 000 a year
okay
well maybe i do like that we've got we
have got to get this income up what are
you doing for work
um i deliver for amazon i am getting a
second job i'm a bartender during the
peak season especially throughout the
summer so i'll be making
you i usually make like eight to nine
hundred um a week there all right i'm
just gonna bump up my money well in new
york city people drink year-round i
found so i'm gonna be doing that every
weekend yeah is that possible if
possible
yeah definitely i i just had an
interview yesterday for another place so
i start next week okay are you doing a
monthly budget
yes
okay we need to tighten that thing down
i'm gonna go ahead and gift you one year
of ramsay plus if you'll watch all the
videos in financial peace university you
can get every dollar plus hang online
kelly will get that for you but man
we've got to create margin here and we
have to get rid of this car so if you
can save up that six grand and be done
with this car
and the difference that's what i'd be
doing or you go get a quick
loan get a thousand dollars on top of it
by a thousand dollar beater get rid of
this thing and now you owe eight
thousand dollars instead of saying and
get the worst car you have ever seen in
your life the more you hate it the more
i know it's the right car for you right
now you're broke dude you're living in
new york city making 30 grand and you're
26 in debt this is a problem but we're
rooting for you call us back when you're
debt-free call us back if we can help it
anyway this is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
deloni our question of the day comes
from blinds.com blinds.com's 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more you can use the
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
all right today's question comes from
jan in indiana jan writes my husband and
i are in our early 50s and earn about 14
000 a month we owe 120 grand in consumer
debt and 180 000 on our home
with our income i think we can pay off
our debt by sticking to a budget
my husband thinks we need to sell our
property which is worth close to a
million bucks because the feeling of
being instantly out of debt will bring
us peace
he's worried because we don't have any
retirement savings i can't seem to help
him that with budgeting and sacrifice we
can be debt-free and still remain in our
home
if we sell i'm afraid he will be filled
with regret over losing a home that we
both love
how do we navigate this conversation of
whether to dig in and pay off the debt
or sell and be completely debt-free and
also have money left over for retirement
as well
so george this is really a two-part
question one is math right one is should
we sell this thing or not like let's
look at the numbers here
i think underneath that question
is a terrified wife i'm about to lose
the home that i love yeah a terrified
husband who said thinking to himself i
haven't taken care of my family
um and i feel like i've got a lottery
ticket right now because house prices
are inflated right
and i could get it all back with one
move i could put it all on red 37 i
could get it all back right
um
so to answer
let's do this in reverse order george
like how do we navigate this
conversation of whether to dig in and
pay off the debt
what i see george most couples get this
conversation wrong
is they
approach this conversation about should
we sell the house or not should we is it
a good financial move
the question here is i'm terrified
i need you to hear me say i don't want
to sell this house and i'm afraid if we
do i'm going to regret it you're going
to regret it and we've worked a long
time to get this home thing the way it
where it is so this conversation starts
not with i'm worried about what you're
going to do this is you saying
i'm absolutely terrified put the fears
on the table what are you scared about
and he's going to say we got nothing
we're in our 50s now we've got no
retirement and i'm looking i'm staring
down the barrel of
10 or 20 more years of working years and
then what do i do you know what i mean
both of them are scared they both need
to say that because that's a humanizing
thing and it puts them both on the same
page now we're both scared we got all
our fears on the table no secrets now we
can go ahead and say okay how do we
solve this problem now we can look at
the math right and so what i would tell
him
is this
i get it
i get it
but here's what's going to happen
you haven't stuck by a budget you don't
have the
behaviors you don't have the actions as
a part of who you are as part of your
identity
so you can go get um you can go get lap
band surgery
if you don't commit to doing life
differently after that to also having
counseling also getting some people
around you some nutritional support
you're you're going to end up where you
were so you're going to sell this house
you're going to pay off all your debt
you're going to be debt-free you're
going to try to find some really tiny
house
and then you go with you and now we're
right back to the guy who doesn't follow
the budget who doesn't get on board with
his wife who doesn't do things together
right see what i'm saying so you end up
with the same thing you haven't
addressed the core symptoms here exactly
leapfrogging and getting the get out of
jail free card by selling the house i'm
not mad at that option occasionally or i
mean yeah yeah it's a viable option but
they don't if they made 4k a month i'd
say yeah you guys are broke they make
14k a month they're making 168 a year
and they have 120 in consumer debt so
math gives me hope in a situation like
this because i look at and go all right
if we can put 10k of the 14 towards debt
we're debt-free in 12 months in one year
we're completely consumer debt free and
doing the same thing 18 months after
that we don't have a mortgage anymore
right so in two and a half years total
you went from 300 000 in debt to not
owing anyone anything and now we can
invest like crazy and let's be clear
this is that's i mean you're asking them
to suck it up yeah this is a major life
change but i want you to hear what she's
saying
she's not saying i'm worried about him
she's saying because my husband won't be
responsible i'm about to lose my house
that's what she's saying and when he
hears that he's going to go whoa whoa
whoa
i don't want that i don't want that to
be the message here
let's make some major changes for 28 to
32 months yeah and let's change
everything what i like about plan one
with jan's plan is going hey let's say
we have a paid for house in two and a
half years and no debt we can still sell
the house if our retirement is not
looking good and things go haywire we
can downsize and we'll be okay yeah we
can survive in retirement and then let's
start putting eight to nine thousand
dollars a month into retirement and
really start hitting the gas crank it up
right yeah so i like plan one because i
think the behavior change is going to
affect the marriage it's going to affect
her life in the best way possible versus
leap frogging that's right so thanks for
the question james great question and by
the way i'm right here with her husband
if i look at that same picture i'd be
thinking i could just get us out of this
right now i get that i get that i get
that um i'd rather see you change change
your identity
all right let's go to the phones this
hour it's a free call triple eight eight
two five five two two five mike joins us
in buffalo new york mike welcome to the
ramsey show
hey guys thanks for having me sure how
can we help
okay so i'm 28 um i'm
i'm living at home i actually moved out
of a apartment that i was i was living
at um it was just too much rent so i i
decided to move back um i got a little
beater car now
um
and you know i depleted my thousand
dollar emergency fund to get it
but now i
i want to move back out and i just don't
know
if i should be
saving up the thousand before i move out
or if i should
kind of treat this like
sort of an emergency i guess why do you
want to move out
um
i'm in a relationship right now and it's
not uh
not the best situation um
we you know we don't see each other too
much and it's just um
um
i feel it's kind of putting a strain on
things to be honest yeah
um
are you safe at home
yeah no it's it's great i mean as far as
um you know i have a great relationship
with my parents it's just um
you know everything outside of that
it sounds to me like you're gonna trade
one strain for another
that you're going to trade
financial strain get your feet under you
i mean what what are we talking we're
talking like three more months 90 more
days 120 days
of yeah hammering it
like
man if your relationship can't if you're
with somebody and they and you say hey
man for the next three or four months
i'm gonna i'm gonna make a move it's
gonna change our future forever my
future forever and they're not
all in your corner hundred percent then
that that bodes that's that's a that's a
that's a shadow over your relationship
um
if you run out for this new relationship
um you're going to not be able to go out
you're going to find yourself in debt
you're going to end up back in these
same places and then at some point my
brother i'm telling you you're gonna get
back in your parents house i'd much
rather see you just suck it up and get
this thing knocked out
okay mike what's your income right now
um i
um i got a i got a new job about two
months ago i'm making about 40k a year
okay
you need to save this baby step one in a
few weeks
and it may mean taking some extra side
jobs right now baby step one is very
fast so no you there's no pausing baby
step one it's a number of days so
there's no pausing here dude you have
zero dollars to your name yeah and you
don't even pay rent how are you able to
save this thing up so fast how old are
you
i'm 28. how much debt do you have
uh about just under 30 000.
yeah man
there's something i'm not i'm missing
because you've got crisis in your voice
and the numbers aren't telling me crisis
what's the panic
um
so i mean the past couple years i mean
i've been listening to you guys for you
know for about three years you know dave
and everybody else um i i've
i've wanted to do
you know follow the plan um
yeah i actually just joined uh fpu just
yesterday i'm doing all my class and you
know i want to take this more serious
because
um
you know it just seems like with you
know relationships and and
even even work life has just been so
volatile in the past couple couple of
years even before the pandemic started
that's right so here's
let's let's let today be the day
what's the day be the day man
i don't want you calling back in three
more years saying well it's just been a
crazy time that's right dude life's
crazy you need some stability in your
life and that means getting that baby
step one paying off your debt and then
we can focus on moving out and focusing
on this relationship you're too broke to
be in a relationship right now you can't
breathe and you need some little wins
brother
you signed up that's a win you need to
get that thousand dollar emergency fund
this month that's a win we're gonna keep
inching towards this thing okay i'm
proud of you
today's the day
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america this is the ramsay
show i'm george campbell joined today by
dr john deloney
all right john we got to talk about
something because it's on everyone's
hearts and minds and that is cars
everyone's losing their minds the car
market
up in here up in here and we are both uh
are in the market for a car and it's a
very stressful time when you're trying
to do it especially with cash
okay so you are currently purchasing one
i did recently a few months ago
it was the strangest interaction i've
ever had
when it comes to transaction
it got to where
i wrote a check and i was looking at the
salesman and i
because it was like hey well we need to
like talk to you about this and you know
if you finance it here and i said look
dude
i gotta check
and it got i felt like i was talking to
my son i said i want to give you this
and i want you to give me that
right i have money
you have the key i can see it just give
me that and i'll give you this like well
you know we gotta we gotta go through
these meetings and i said i'm not gonna
buy any of your special clear coats i
don't want any extended warranty i just
want that could you just take this can i
just give you this can i just give you
this man it was such an event that i
ended up leaving and then we called back
and i said hey how about this just bring
it by
we literally like a mile and a half down
there just drop it off here i'll give
you this giant check for it
you would dude it was easier to buy my
house than it was to buy a car with cash
wow and you you're in the middle of it
now has it gotten worse yeah yeah i just
tried yesterday and here's the thing
okay so don't fill me in on this i'm
like literally american article to you
to prove what i'm experiencing okay wall
street journal here's the headline car
dealerships don't want your cash oh
there you go they want to give you a
loan there you go buyers say dealerships
are pushing them to borrow because they
make more money that way the hot car
market is giving them the opportunity so
every time in history
it's if you'll pay with cash it's
actually cheaper yeah we'll get the deal
done faster and now they're charging
they're up charging you right yes and uh
the the numbers show this john if you
finance a car the dealership makes you
know three four thousand dollars if you
just pay cash
they're gonna make hundreds of dollars
maybe a thousand so they're making way
less if you pay cash they're making
money off the financing deals if they
can get you to finance they get
kickbacks from the lenders they have
their own financing they're making money
from that and so it's actually
increasingly difficult to buy a car with
cash now this is not your excuse america
to go well i'm gonna go get a car loan
because it's too hard to pay with cash
i'm not gonna get a discount you still
have to pay with cash you will not go
into debt for a car but here's my
experience john i said hey uh yeah i'm
not gonna finance i was just straight up
with them which you know problem number
one honesty shouldn't have done that and
they go okay well it's gonna cost you a
thousand dollars more
if you're gonna pay in full
and i went okay well i guess you're not
getting my business then
and so i just said
let's be clear
the check you're about to write it's a
decent size check yeah it's a good chat
yeah and so i said here's what i'm
willing to pay
you call me back if you can do that
otherwise the end of the conversation
and that's what happened and i just got
a text while we're doing the show that
was like hey
let's talk asap i've got some updates
for you and so this is the digital
version of the walk away
so here's what this comes down to the
walkway you just walk out of the
dealership
they chase you out and go no john john
john come back in and so here's what i
want you to know
the person with the most patience the
most information and the most options
always wins
in any spending decision
when you're not desperate you can make a
better decision when you have options
you can make a better decision when
you're willing to walk a resource yes so
here's what i want to tell you guys do
your research there's so many avenues
online to research the exact car you
want
you will know more than the dealership
does about that car by the time you walk
in there
number two i want you to make sure that
you know the exact value of your
trade-in and here's the thing if you've
got a trade-in appraise it before you
get the out the door price because
otherwise they start finagling it
on the back end they wind it down to
charge you more yeah when you say no no
you said my car's worth 4 000. that's
what we're going to do here and the out
the door price includes all the taxes
and fees the doc fees all that stuff
that is the number we need to aim at
now you don't have to say hey i'm not
going to finance today you can save that
to the end if you really want to you
know stick the knife in and go slap the
check on the tape see i'm like you i'm
like hey it's a cash deal i want to walk
out today with this car i've already
i've already driven it i want that one
can we just not play a game yes they do
the four square and they go we can get
your payments down to whatever you want
yeah not really that kind of guy no it's
cool
so here's what i want you to do go in
with a cashier's check maybe a little
bit below the asking price like here's
what i would love to pay for this car
and when they see that check in hand
they're still gonna go well we can make
twenty six thousand dollars right now or
we can hope that someone finances it in
the next month or we get a car off our
lot and get a trade-in now if they go
above that cashier's check and you still
feel like it's a good deal
that's okay you can supplement that with
your own check with cash whatever that
looks like so you don't need the exact
number
on the table there and i do think it's
important to call it here so
there's a whole bunch of car dealerships
trying to do right by people
um some good guys great guy larry and
paducah that's a lot of our people here
at ramsey do business with a great human
being that's trying to help people out
trying to put them in cars and so this
isn't all car dealerships are bad and i
hadn't bought a car in a long time and
it used to be they put something in the
paper i don't know if you remember what
that those days were like but or they
put some online and then you go haggle i
do understand now like after talking
with the guys and getting some more
information that buying a car is
different now the the idea you're gonna
go in and get eight thousand dollars off
those days are not here yes right so
as a buyer don't be a jerk don't be a
[ __ ] don't squeeze the um yeah i'm
gonna be kind be a good human being yeah
say this is what i can afford to pay i
want that car let's make it let's shake
hands and then if you can't walk out the
door yes but agreeing on that out the
door price is the key yeah because if
you agree on that then it doesn't matter
what they say about financing you know
we agreed this is the price of the car
and please please look at the contract
and if there's anything beyond a small
doc fee in your sales tax for the state
county you live in
run if they're trying to tack on all
these extra things and warranties they
force walk out of there so i'm not
paying anything but a small doc fee and
if you can get rid of that that's even
better and then the taxes which yes we
have to pay our taxes on these on sales
tax on these cars yeah so do that walk
in with a cashier's check don't walk in
with a barrel full of cash of actual
physical dollars that is a terrible move
it's dangerous they've got to report it
to the irs they don't want to deal with
that hassle so yes we say pay cash we
don't actually mean take a briefcase
like it's a you know an old old school
movie it's kind of baller though it is
i've known people who've done it and
they get laughed out of there they go go
get a cashier's check we're not gonna
we're not playing that game
so be patient do your research know your
options don't go on a saturday when it's
packed out go at the end of the month on
a week night when it's not raining so
that you can actually do the inspection
and not be in a rush and that's going to
help you make the best financial
decision and be willing to sacrifice i
know you wanted this exact specification
it's okay if you've got another option
you're desperate
then you got to deal with that but
here's the other thing don't buy a car
right now unless you absolutely have to
yeah don't buy car
ta-da get it fixed
that's right james gets it
now ken and i took uh
ken and i took a call about a snosberry
jeep and the wife really wanted this
exact jeep color was the only one
to get and we had to talk her off the
ledge and i was like snozzberry's not
even a color let's not pretend that you
need this exact jeep at this exact time
that's like a willy wonka candy bar
isn't it yeah
exactly it's from willy wonka snozzberry
jeep ah very stressful stuff i'm in
james did we hit everything in this
article i was gonna say what about
private sale private sale let's talk
about private sale john this is very
important as well okay that is when you
can actually negotiate is with a private
sale you can get more money if you're
selling that way and you can actually
negotiate because if i'm just going to
john he's got no incentives from the
financing lenders to make money he needs
money he just wants the money he wants
to sell his car so i would be on
facebook marketplace looking for these
there's some third-party sites like auto
trader where people are just listing
their cars for sale so that's where i
would start my research and see if i can
work it out and always always get an
inspection on the car from a mechanic
this will cost you about 100 bucks but
no matter who's selling it go get an
inspection from a reputable mechanic
before you go slap 10 grand down because
it's a deal and then you find out there
are some major issues that you didn't
know about until you're going over 60 on
the interstate and it starts rattling
right transmission falls out yes so
you've got to do the inspection
negotiate with cash in hand be a kind
person
commit say hey i've got cash today if
you can do this deal i'll show up
and so that uh that's how to navigate
this market john it's not fun i totally
feel empathy for people that really need
a car and you can find a car by the way
that's under fifteen thousand dollars
under ten thousand we get a lot of flack
for that people go you can't find a car
you can't beat your cars they don't
exist go to auto trader wherever and do
sort by lowest price thanks there's some
great cars for four or five thousand
dollars three thousand dollars suck it
up no one's gonna stop you in a parking
lot and be like
yeah i want some of this no it's not
that kind of car been stopped but it'll
get you where you need to go that's
right well that puts this hour of the
remedy show in the books my thanks to
john deloney my co-host and all the
folks in the booth who are doing a great
job keeping the lights on and you
america we appreciate you listening
we'll be back with you before you know
it
[Music]
hey it's john dolone co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your
boundaries your mental health your
relationships your career all of it and
we do it right in front of you here on
the ramsey show open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to call i'm george
campbell joined today by my good friend
dr john deloney and together we
hopefully can help you that is the hope
john that's the hope i see you're
milking this my good friend thing but
i'll take it thank you samantha is
kicking off this hour she's in austin
texas samantha welcome to the show
hi good afternoon thank you guys for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help
um so i'm in a bit of a dilemma
i had bought a house a couple years ago
when i was married and
since then i've become divorced
and so
uh
something that i've been trying to
decide on is if i'm going to stay in the
house or if i am going to
sell it
and then recently i have looked more
into it
and
i actually um this week put it up
on a market or listing with some real
estate agents in our area and received a
really good offer um but as i got the
offer i kind of
am debating i guess you can say um
i want to sell it to pay off all the
debts that i've incurred since getting
the house yeah well samantha i'm so
sorry that you you've gone through this
still going through this grieving from
this that's one of the most difficult
things a person can experience
um thank you how much debt do you
have um so i have about 70 000 in debt
uh yeah 30 of it came from repairs that
we did on the house over the last three
years and then
the other 40 000 in student loan debt
okay and then what's your equity going
to be if you if you took this offer that
you have in front of you
what's your it would be about 50 000
so you'd still owe 20 after the sale
yes it would i i would pay off
definitely uh the repairs for the house
so that i could get rid of it all
together um and then just keep the
student loan debt like pay off most of
it and then have that about 20 000 left
what do you do for a living
i'm a teacher
okay so you're about
55 65 000 a year income
about 50. about 50. okay
okay so what's the financial picture
look like with this house is it can you
afford the payment did you refinance
um yes i actually did refinance um from
a 30-year mortgage to a 15-year mortgage
um
just a little bit after the divorce and
uh it puts a lot more towards the actual
house payment versus uh
sure the interest what's the percentage
of your take-home pay that the mortgage
is going towards
um i i pay 900 to my mortgage and my
take home pay is about three a little
over three thousand
okay
so
your debt to income ratio is an
emergency but it's not caustic
you hear what i'm saying it's not like
you make fifty thousand dollars a year
and you owe three hundred thousand
dollars
right you owe seventy it's a lot and
you're gonna have to work really hard
it's gonna take you a while to pay it
all off
but
but i also on the other side
understand
um from just sitting with people for
years
when you have the loss of uh somebody
passes away that you love like your
husband or your wife right when you have
a divorce and you have these major
events there's something about i need i
need to i need everything to be
different now
right i need to change it all
and
i'm not i'm getting from you and you
tell me if i'm wrong push back on me
that you don't love this house
but if you sell this house
your old life is official it's over
there's a period at the end of that
sentence and you know that you need to
do that but you don't
it's so hard to actually walk out of
that funeral home
am i right
am i right or wrong i didn't like that
but i mean i i can definitely see how
that's right i think there's a part of
me that loves the house because we've
put so much into it
um but there's also
the key word there is we
right
and this was our house and now it's just
my house and there's something weird
about that
i don't george you i don't i won't i
won't
i think this is one of those rare
moments that you do what's best for you
yeah i mean i'm looking at the financial
picture and i'm going with rent right
now if you sold this thing you're paying
900 right now you're going to jump to 15
1800 to go rent somewhere and trying to
find another house i mean what are the
home prices in your area could you even
get something else you're in austin it's
bunkers and you're in debts you have no
money so you're going to have to rent
so i imagine rent is more than 900 in
austin right now
um can i add to that um
so i would actually go and live with a
relative and so
it would
basically cut what i'm paying in half
like including utilities and all that my
money costs for is that is that a good
move or is that a i'm running are you
running two something or away from
something
oh neither it was just i was trying to
figure out what i could do financially
like because i don't want to be in debt
and it all sort of came on within the
past three years
because before i only had my student
loans
i mean i like that option if it's a good
relationship and they're okay with it
but i would set boundaries for what this
looks like this is not a forever thing
hey one year from now after i move in
i'm gonna move out because i'm gonna
have my debt paid off and have an
emergency fund or we're going to do this
for 18 months i'm going to pay you this
when do you want me in
uh we're not going to have dinner every
night together i'm busy i'm a teacher
also this summer i'm going to get a
second job and work like
a maniac because i'm going to get this
debt paid out you see what i'm saying
yes
okay so here's what i'm thinking
samantha if you've got that situation
i'm going to sell the house
then you're going to have 20 000 left on
the student loans you're going to then
pay that those student loans off very
quickly and save up three to six months
in an emergency fund once you do that i
think then we need to go okay we're
gonna leave we're gonna fly the coop
we're gonna go rent somewhere we're
gonna start saving up a down payment
while we're renting and we're going to
take the extra jobs we're going to tutor
on the side it's going to be a grind
regardless
or
i'm going to repaint the living room
myself i'm going to repaint the bedroom
myself
and i'm going to stay in this house i'm
only paying 900 bucks a month it's
continuing to appreciate everyone on
planet earth is trying to move to austin
right now so i'm in a good spot but i
need some healing but i can do that here
yeah i think it's a question that you
got to answer i'd love to see you do the
math on this what is actually playing
400 bucks a month 450 bucks a month over
the like how much faster would this how
much faster is that gonna get me out of
debt save up three to six months of
emergency fund like how is that going to
work for me versus staying here yeah
either way there's gonna be a lot of
sacrifice in the next two three years of
your life
but man it will set you free if you if
you can go either way and get rid of
this debt and have that weight not
hanging on your shoulders on top of a
recent divorce you're gonna be a new
woman and you're gonna have a new
picture of what life for samantha looks
like in austin yeah i hate this for you
though i hate that you're here yeah
thank you so much for the call samantha
we're pulling for you especially for
teachers john i know you have a big
heart for teachers
it's a tough time to be a teacher let
alone our divorce teacher right now yeah
it's just it's yeah it's just a lot of
rejection tough and this one of those
mushy answers that it's either way six
or eight doesn't another what's best for
you but i get that there's a lot of
emotion wrapped up but i don't want is
is the foot goes off the pedal and we
just get comfortable there you go so
either way this dead is going to be out
of our lives sooner rather than later
thanks so much for the call this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show
all right folks if you've ever been to
one of our live events you know they're
a starting point for huge life change
these are sell out action-packed events
and it's time to bring them back on the
road and we are not holding back this
year first up we've got building wealth
live it's coming to orlando on thursday
may 19th and this thing is selling fast
so if you're waiting around to buy your
ticket don't do that it's going to sell
out and you'll want to stay tuned
because we'll be announcing cities for
five more of these building wealth
events very soon we're also bringing our
largest event of the year to dallas on
october 22nd that's right smart
conference is back there's really no
better way to spend a saturday than
gathering with a community of people who
are all motivated to make a real change
in their lives that's what smart
conference is all about don't miss it
guys i'll be at both of those events
john will be at both of those events
we're going to have a great time and if
you want to learn more about them
visit ramseysolutions.com
events we would love to see you in your
community on the road all right let's go
to celeste she joins us in san diego
celeste welcome to the show how you
doing
hi hi thanks for taking my call
um i'm 32 years old i have an extra 30
000 saved what do you think i should do
with the money i have a student loan of
about 15 000
a car loan of about 20 000
and then um
a mortgage um
but no ira no 401k just trying to figure
out
get ideas about what next step should be
sure well i appreciate the call how long
you been listening to us
for a very long time so i do know about
the baby steps and
you know just kind of reluctant paying
off the
um just the
car loan and
student loan
because with the student loan i don't
know whether or not um there's actually
going to be student loan forgiveness so
i'm holding off on that
with the car loan
it's just
you know sometimes too it's nice to be
able to see kind of that that 30 cages
sitting there in case this celeste
you're you're looking at everything
through some rose-colored glasses right
now and i want you to look at reality
you are you're all of that hard work
that you're putting in
is keeping you broke because you're
making those payments to lenders every
month and there's just as much of a
chance as a creator taking us all out as
there is of you getting those student
loans forgiven i mean it's one percent
that's the actual number of people who
have applied and have actually gotten
forgiveness is one percent so
do you have any money in savings right
now other than the 30k is that
everything to your name
about 30 30k yeah okay so i want you to
follow this plan not because we're so
right but it's because the plan works
every time you work it so 1 000 of that
we're going to keep in the savings 29 of
that we're going to throw at the debt in
order of smallest to largest so it
sounds like the student loans are gone
today
and most of the credit card debt is gone
today right
leaving you with six thousand to pay off
what's your income
about
k heck yeah so last you're debt-free
like in a month and a half
so 92k you've got some freedom payments
right because you got rid of the student
loan debt you got rid of most of the
credit card debt and so that 6k is going
to be gone really fast then we're going
to build up three to six months for
emergencies in a savings account and
then we can move on to investing so i
know you said you don't have an ira 401k
you're 32. you've got a good 30 years
left to invest and become a millionaire
and you'll get there but we got to start
doing we got to start doing things in
order on purpose and right now we're
kind of just floating and hoping and
maybe this will happen and i kind of
like seeing the money over here and it
sounds like you're comfortable with your
financial situation when you really
should be angry at it but and i want you
two things okay can i give you two hard
pieces of reality
uh-huh here's hard piece number one
you are renting your perceived security
that that 30 000 you see in the bank
you're renting that feeling
from your car loan people and from the
credit card people and from the
uh higher ed loan folks
so whatever you're paying in interest
whatever is accruing that's the monthly
charge
for you to go oh but look at that 30 000
it's so cute it keeps me safe and so
you're you're paying for that okay it's
costing you money
the other thing and this is i've i've
had a uh close friends in higher ed who
are professors who argue with me about
this
this is my take on the student loan
thing
i when i went to college was a
uneducated naive 18 year old and i took
out a bunch of loans
then i went to grad school my wife went
to grad school we kept going to grad
school we kept taking on more loans to
the tune of six figures a lot
i didn't fully understand what i was
getting into and by i didn't fully i had
no idea what i was doing to my long-term
life
and
i looked at somebody and said if you
will help me get through college i'll
pay you back
i signed my name to that paper and said
i owe you this money
and so for me paying loans back
instead of like i'm waiting on this
thing it wasn't that i have some of my
law students
they
they specifically went into different
forms of law that pay way less money
because they want to serve their
communities that's a different thing
because they show cancer the government
and the government has completely
screwed him on that deal
but for the rest of us who are just like
well i heard it's going to go away so
i'm just going to sit on it
i went back to the mirror it's an
integrity issue for me i said i'd pay
you back and so i'm going to and so
waiting around are they going to punt it
are they going to move just get rid of
it you said you'd pay it back you got
the cash pay it back and be done with
your life and if you pay it back and
then monday biden comes out and it's
like you're all free you can go ah that
sucks and then you're gonna go about
your life move on you know what i mean
and you're gonna know i
was a person of integrity i did what i
said i was going to do i paid back the
money that i was owed and then i'm going
to move back on with my life very
similar to when dave declared bankruptcy
which is legal all his debts went away
and then he started this business and he
made a bunch of money he went back and
paid them all back
because he said i said i was going to
pay you that's the right thing to do so
that's a not popular opinion when it
comes to higher ed i know people get got
ripped off and signed up on things they
did i get all that and i'm not against
forgiveness
but right now you got the money and you
said you're gonna pay him back and so i
say pay him back and move on about your
day yeah you're in a great situation
celeste with the fact that you've got a
great income and you actually have money
most people who call in are making
thirty thousand dollars they have zero
dollars to their name and they have
thirty 35 000 in debt
so take advantage of the situation by
being done with this debt forever and i
see myself in celeste because
when i was 24 i had 40 000 in debt and i
didn't even make half of what celeste
made yeah i mean like maybe a third of
that and i got out of debt in two years
which tells me celeste can do it a whole
lot faster especially with this chunk of
change she has that's right
good stuff all right let's go to kelly
in san diego kelly welcome to the show
hi john hi george how are you guys doing
what's up how can we help
um so i'm 22 years old and my question
is
i went to a university for a year and
then some community college but i just
really don't think college is for me but
i do really want to be successful
you know i think i have a pretty good
working background for my age but i
don't i don't really know what i want to
do in the long term and is it even
possible for me to be successful without
a degree yes absolutely
that was easy so no you don't need to go
to college but yes you do need to figure
out what that thing is
and get the right education and skills
to do that if you want to be a surgeon a
nurse a doctor an engineer an architect
you need to go to college
if you want to be a famous writer
that will give you a leg up there's a
lot of things you can do college really
is great for you
one of the one of the myths we have
right now is that you should pay a
hundred grand and just kind of fish tail
around and figure out what it is on the
way
um just vibe it out yeah you just vibe
it out you're in a position right now
that i think it'd be great if you have
no idea what you want to do which i
don't think that's true i bet if we
pressed on it a little bit if ken was
here he could drill down real quick you
probably have some things that you love
and that you're really good at
i'd love to see you work really really
really hard over the next 12 to 18
months get around some people who are
ahead of you and some jobs see what
that's like what management's like
what's doing some other stuff's like and
then it will begin to shape what you
actually want to do hang on the line
here we'll give you a copy of ken's
career assessment get clear get clear
assessment and then it kind of helps you
hey what do i want to do and we'll give
you a copy of his best-selling book from
paycheck to purpose that kind of walks
through how do i find this job that i
love
i mean the data is true you go to
college over the long run you're gonna
make more money you can do some stuff
but there's a bunch of jobs millions of
jobs that are desperate for people that
require no the data also shows that
people are broke even with their degrees
in great jobs because they can't breathe
with student loan payments so you don't
need to go to college hang on kelly's
going to pick up she'll get you from
paycheck to purpose and the get clear
assessment appreciate the call this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again
it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined by dr john deloney you
hear us say all the time folks that
everyone needs a will and it's true it's
a basic adult responsibility and there's
no good excuse not to have one the
fastest most cost effective way to get
your will taken care of is by doing it
online and a lot of folks ask us a
simple if a simple online whale is right
for everybody and i get that what if you
need a trust or a mirror will what about
powers of attorney and all kinds of
things well to help you answer those
questions our team built a really simple
easy quiz that will help you decide on
the right option you'll get custom
results based on basic info like if
you're single or married where you live
or even the size of your estate once
you're done you'll know exactly what you
need and you're going to understand it
way better so visit ramseysolutions.com
will's quiz to check it out for yourself
the quiz takes a few minutes and it'll
put you on the path to protect your
family and your wishes that's ramsey
solutions dot com slash wills quiz all
right let's go to the phones this hour
caleb joins us in indianapolis caleb
welcome to the show
hey how are you guys doing what's up man
oh not much um i had kind of a career
question for you guys um i started a new
job about two months ago and that time
i've been fully remote
the day actually not the day but the
week i started the company instituted a
booster requirement okay but since we've
been fully remote they haven't really
enforced it however today they basically
said a month from today everyone has to
be in the office two days a week and
they are enforcing the booster
um so i'm just kind of at a crossroads
like i i'm not boosted um trying to
figure out
kind of the best way to handle this
especially being so in so new into the
role just kind of the best way to go
about this
so
um man i've had this conversation a lot
over the last
especially the last year
um
here's the simplest way to go about it
do you want to get the booster
and keep your job
or do you feel strongly about not
getting the booster and you're just
going to need to go find another job
yeah
and
what i've found is any other
angst you give yourself any other rage i
get all that whatever side of this you
follow
but any any additional
weight you bring to the conversation
beyond answering those two questions is
a choice for you you're choosing to be
more miserable don't do that
if you feel really strongly i'm not
doing this great
go get another job just be in the market
today start applying today you got all
weekend get after it
if you say man i hate this but i'm gonna
go ahead and do it great then go do it
with a smile on your face and then going
about your day
anything other than that is a choice to
be miserable you see what i'm saying
yeah yeah i know that that makes sense
it's it's just difficult because it was
like you know this requirement was in
place when i was going through the
process i wouldn't have even accepted
the job and then i was like well maybe i
can make it work for you know as long as
they'll let me and then obviously today
that kind of all blew up so that's right
um
just trying to understand and also
trying to make a clear decision not
obviously a little emotional just you
know the
suddenness of it um coming on today but
also understanding i have kind of a
month-long runway to figure out what i
need to do but just kind of want to get
an outside opinion yeah kind of the best
way to how old are you about it
i'm 26 26 all right so this is this your
first or second third big job
uh this is my second job i actually just
left um in at the end of the year my
first job out of college for this
position okay so um
the vaccine is a it's a lightning rod
okay and you are wise beyond your ears
to say i wanna i wanna exhale a little
bit and get some perspective
but here's what i wanna tell you
for the rest of your life
jobs you take are gonna you're gonna
you're gonna start a job on monday and
you're gonna get re-orged on tuesday i
started this job with no radio
experience in an 18-month plan to learn
how this thing works and then kova
kicked off and dave said well
congratulations you're on the radio
right we had to figure this out live and
i man i've made a train wreck of a few
things and so
then there's a reorg and there's this
and then hey we're not going to be able
to do retirement funding matching this
year because we're having it's always
going to be a thing
and so
and this is with all of your
relationships all of your life there's
always going to be a thing i'm living in
a house and then the
the county raises my taxes
the i live in a country and now they
require whatever the thing is
make the decision you're going to make
and then be at peace with it and go on
about your day don't choose to stew and
spin and be angry and talk about it and
call everybody on facebook about
that's just choosing misery and that
misery has a physical toll on your heart
on your brain on your body don't do it
just say i'm in or i'm out and then i'm
gonna go on about it and you're making
grown-up decisions with whatever for
whatever reason great man i'm proud of
you
do you have somebody in your life that
you trust that you can sit on and talk
to
yeah i mean i'm married and we're we're
in a good church too so so
i reach out to
a man that you trust not to say your
wife's gonna be your wife is
is going to be team caleb
um
or maybe she's going to be absolutely
opposite team caleb if you're in my
house um but find a man in your church
there's 10 years down the road it's 35
40 and say hey can i take you can i take
you out for coffee here's what i'm
wrestling with i just started this job
here so i'm thinking through
and let them speak some wisdom into you
and i'm not saying wisdom on what you
should do but it helps take the emotion
out of this thing we can look at this
objectively i do that when i get
emotional about decisions and i still do
right um i get somebody that i trust to
help me walk through it i make the
decision then i'm on about my day man
just because i'm not going to choose to
poison myself that does that make sense
yep caleb i'm less emotional than john
definitely hopefully yeah so i'll walk
you through a different scenario here
how much do you make right now
um with a bonus i'm at 101. wow way to
go man 101 at 26 years old you're
crushing it so
tell me this
here's how i look at it if someone said
hey if you get the booster i'll give you
a hundred one thousand dollars a year
forever i'd be like okay well now it's a
decision to consider but if you say hey
my principles my values tell me no it's
not worth that well then we have to turn
that down and go okay i gotta go find to
work somewhere else that will hopefully
pay me that much or more that will allow
me to still have these values and
beliefs does that make sense
so what's your line of work
i'm an accountant okay cool so in
accountant world
you can find another accounting job in
indianapolis right that may have
less you know less strict policies
or you may or here's the thing your
values may say i can't be in
indianapolis anymore your values may say
i can't be in this community like what
you see what i'm saying so it's where
these values go and they're your values
that's the beauty of them and i'm going
to pick them i'm going to hold them firm
and then i'm going to go about my life
right yeah and yeah if the matrix is
um there's not a lot i wouldn't do for a
hundred one thousand dollars i just try
to take the emotions out of it for a
second and go okay let's look at
logic on paper
versus just the emotions
both are important the other side is
yeah i won't work for a company who
chooses to insert themselves into my
life at this level i don't want that
sort of
um control right great man
and then be at peace with it
yep yeah and that's what i've been
struggling with it's like if you can't
trust me to make like a medical decision
for myself how can you even trust me to
like do my job correctly and that's i
think that's really like what i've been
wrestling with so hey i'm so excited so
here's what i want to i want to really
caution you against okay i'm glad you
mentioned this there's a it's an old
psychological principle called the
fundamental attribution error okay
it's when you get inside somebody else's
head
and try to decide for them why they just
did what they did
and then you respond to your perception
of why they did what they just did and
you get mad about it or angry about it
or happy about it or whatever so what
i'll tell you is get out of people's
heads whether it's your wife whether
it's your workplace just look at the
policy on the paper
they're asking me to do this this
violates my values i got a month cool
i'm out have a great week
here's a micro version of this
you walk in from a hard day of
accounting and your wife left her shoes
by the door again and you trip over them
and you can think she just did that to
make me
dude
you could get in her head and think that
or
you could say man my wife's probably
really exhausted and something must be
going on i'm gonna pick these things up
and i'm gonna do the dishes too right so
you get to pick how you respond here i'd
say get out of your company's head they
don't trust me to nope there's nothing
to do with you they made a policy
just say am i gonna follow this policy
or not and then i'm going about my day
one of those choices is filled with
anxiety and one is just the freedom this
is life what am i gonna do next that's
right yeah well good luck with the
decision caleb no matter what you end up
with but you're crushing it man 26 100k
not so bad i'll take that this is the
ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by dr
john deloney this is the ramsay show
our scripture of the day comes from
hebrews 10 23
let us hold unswervingly to the hope we
profess for he who promised is faithful
henry david thoreau said
none are so old as those who have
outlived enthusiasm
that's really good
good stuff henry wherever he is today
good stuff he's not he's not here george
i know i know it was a joke john thoreau
just sounds like it's from the 1800s so
there we go let's go to the phones this
hour devin joins us in wichita devon
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are you guys doing today great
how can john and i help
i just had a question about
the feeling of resentment towards my
step brother and his girlfriend when
they finance cool items
and me and my wife gave up over time for
those same items hey can you uh devin
talk in directly into your phone there
for me
sorry about that there we go there you
go okay say that again you're so you
have resentment towards your brother and
your sister-in-law because they're
financing things and you save up for
things and paying cash
yes him and his girlfriend are they
financing things through your bank
account
no just it's the idea that they have
cool items now when you my wife are
saving up over time for those cooler
items later on uh what's a cool item
well they just bought a house and
they're both 22 and we're still saving
up for a down payment and i know that
they
they uh loaned a down payment so it's
technically not a down payment but
so
i talked about getting cool cars and
whatnot so a few weeks ago so one cool
thing about working at ramsey is
there's a lot of people have
like this is like a sugar addict's
nightmare there's lots of bowls of candy
around this place
and so i grabbed a handful on the way
out from somebody's desk and
i took it home to my kids
i've got a 11 almost 12 year old and a
six-year-old
and
my six-year-old is allergic to peanuts
and things and so i gave my 11 my 11
year old several pieces of candy
and all i had for
my six-year-old was just a little bit so
i gave it to her
and she's six
and she said
but you gave
him you gave hank this stuff i said yeah
i know and i brought you this
i try to keep you alive
try to keep you from from being dead
and in her six-year-old sweet little
mind there was this great injustice that
had just happened and i tell you this
because she was six
that's six
as a country we have decided that we
don't let her vote or buy guns or drink
beer because she's
six
so
fast forward to you brother devin
why is this getting into you so much you
and your wife are working hard you're
doing right you're trying not to end up
on the side of the road which is where
your
other family members are clearly going
to end up like why is this getting in
your soul so much because you're not six
well
we've we both grew up in families where
financing was just a normal situation
okay um so we've always grew up around
nicer cars or finance cars so they were
always you know year maybe two years
um from new
and ever since i took your guys's course
in high school and
ever since we got married last year
uh we've been living we've never been in
debt before me and her so we've never
had any kind of loans or nothing so
it's always been saving up and saving up
always takes longer than you know it's
easy to just go finance something
so
seeing we're really close to my step
brother and his girlfriend um so we're
constantly hanging out with them and
whenever we go over to their house and
they start talking about how they're
going to go
here in a couple months they're wanting
to go buy a brand new jeep for his
girlfriend and whatnot you know it
sounds awesome and i know that when we
leave their house we're going well you
know
it's pretty stupid that they're doing
that
it's still that feeling of that you know
they're gonna have it though and that's
it's pretty cool so it's just weird
devin have you heard this quote from
carrie fisher resentment is like
drinking poison and waiting for the
other person to die
that's what's happening right now
you're on a different journey if you
didn't know your brother you'd have no
clue if he had a paid for house and a
paid for car or if he was drowning in
debt
so when i pull up to someone at the
stoplight my honda civic it's an 09 with
body damage and the guy next to me is
driving a brand new tesla i don't know
his financial station situation he
doesn't know mine he doesn't know i have
a paid for house and have no debt and it
doesn't matter you could say that's a
really rad car and i do i say man it'd
be nice to have a tesla but i don't have
the money and then
i'm on with my day
here here's the here's the i wanna we're
i'm poking at you devon but here's the
here's the honest truth we do get this
call a lot and we have this conversation
a lot
people make this journey all about the
numbers the dollars and cents the
savings the things we're giving up
and if you do that
your your identity ends up in ash
because everything in your life is about
the stuff we don't have
so the challenge moving forward for you
is to flip the entire way you're looking
at this around
you found an incredible partner you
found a great wife that is on the same
page with you
spiritually psychologically financially
y'all are working towards something and
it's hard
and yes it's cool to ride in a rad jeep
it is you know it's not cool when they
tow it away because i can't afford it or
because they broke up
it's super cool to live in a fancy house
it is not cool to be pacing the house
because you don't know how you're gonna
pay your bills and i've been there i've
done that
where my wife's asleep and i can't
breathe i'm about to throw up and it's
two o'clock in the morning because i
don't know how we're gonna pay our bills
and so i want you to flip this thing
around and not look at the debt-free
journey as an adventure and crap you
don't have
but i want you to flip it around and say
we are on the adventure of a lifetime to
make sure that nobody in devon's family
tree ever deals with this stuff again
you see what i'm saying
yes it's an entire
it's an entire identity shift your
actions day to day will actually be very
similar you're not going to borrow money
you're going to keep saving for things
you're going to pay stuff off as it
comes right you're going to keep doing
the same things
but why you're doing it is so different
not because we're just not going to have
stuff but because we are making it stops
with us those people who think they're
better because they drive fancy cars
they can't afford who live in houses
they can't afford who co-sign on things
with their girlfriends which is just a
disaster you get what i'm saying devin
well here's what i want to do devin i
want to send you a copy of rachel cruz's
book love your life not theirs because
this what this comes down to is
comparisons and you're going well i'm
not where they are dude you're way ahead
it just looks different yeah because
you're looking at things that aren't
real because it's all financed they
don't own any of it and that's okay you
can still love them you can hang out
with them in their beautiful house and
ride in their nice cars you go hey man
that's your journey if you want to know
what i'm up to how i became debt-free
and how we can do all these things over
here let us know and if not that's cool
i'm still your brother yeah
it's just it's not about the shiny stuff
and this is all about an identity shift
yeah but this is a real crisis i think
for this generation especially for the
younger ones well i i it's so much
easier to crush your parents too i mean
that's kind of where we got into all
this it crushed our parents too oh i can
build this bigger house look they've got
two cars like i grew up we only had one
family car and then all of a sudden was
like well the neighbors got two right so
it's been this way forever they've got
that we should get that and it's been
keeping up with the joneses right it's
been forever the problem now is the
joneses are international because we got
these digital boxes so they're ever
everyone's
you scroll and you're like i'll never be
enough yeah i'll never amount to
anything and i used to be able to see my
neighbors two cars but then i would see
like
i don't really want their life i don't
get that and i get the curated version
so i get where devon's at i get it i get
it but man when you can make that shift
and go man
i'm so grateful that we don't have to
make any payments i'm so grateful to
have this level of contentment and where
we're at in the journey and that
sacrifice builds character yeah and that
character will carry you through the
rest of your life so there's a great
thing i learned i rent track in in high
school a little bit in college
thank you for that i appreciate that um
yeah that was my lo-fi uh high school
call back flex what a flex that's right
um
but i learned often when you're
especially when you're training
not to race the people around you race
the clock you're racing you how'd you do
yesterday how are you doing today are
you meeting the goals you set up today
and that you versus that clock man which
means it's you versus you when you're on
this financial journey it's so tempting
to look to your left and your right your
left and your right
it's about where you're headed you can't
run like usain bolt john but you can
beat john from yesterday that's exactly
right and that is the person i'm
competing against well set
love it that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books my thanks to
john deloney my co-host james kelly ben
zach nathan all the folks in the booth
and you america we appreciate you
listening we couldn't do this without
you we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember to
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you